hey ich bin heute abend alleine hier die
anderen packen schon für unsere china
tour die meisten von uns waren morgen
früh schon ab spreche also jetzt den
namen von allen
vielen dank für den preis kannst du den
halten
ich würde heute ein paar sachen
loswerden ich bin ich die
bundesprüfstelle und ich bin auch nicht
die ethikkommission
aber ich stehe hier um für alle zu
sprechen die in diesem punkt so denken
wie ich
verbote und zensur sind sicher nicht die
lösung aber ich hoffe das wird euch
solche auseinandersetzungen wie heute
wieder zu einem anderen bewusstsein
finden in bezug darauf was als
provokation noch erträgliches und das
nicht vielen dank schöner so also ich
will hier keine politik debatte draus
machen
wir sind ja in erster linie um einen
guten abend zu haben und zu feiern
nachdem der ethik ausschuss darüber
entschieden hat und wir uns so oft dazu
geäußert haben sich dann noch als
künstler der aus derselben stadt kommt
wie wir als moralische instanz hierauf
zu spielen und das thema nochmal so auch
zu machen und uns einen pranger zu
stellen ist relativ viel los und geburt
eigentlich einem so großen musiker
nichtsdestotrotz nichtsdestotrotz als
zeichen des friedens habe ich und auch
um zu demonstrieren dass wir rapper
durchaus künstler sind die zeit genutzt
und in zehn minuten ein schönes porträt
gemalt dass ich heute zu einem guten
zweck versteigern werde
bitteschön dankeschön für den echo und
euch einen neuen boss haften abend